en este vídeo vamos a ver un tema que se
desprende del test de hipótesis que es
el llamado error
tipo 1 el error tipo 1 consiste en
rechazar
vamos a escribirlo
la hipótesis nula
aún cuando es verdadera
aun cuando
es verdadera
y vamos a tratar de comprender un poco
de esto nosotros trabajamos el test de
hipótesis con dos hipótesis hipótesis
nula y la hipótesis alternativa dijimos
que si la probabilidad de que ocurra un
evento de hipótesis nula es
supongamos menor al
3%
muchos lo consideran menor el 5% y demás
rechazamos
la hipótesis nula sin embargo y nosotros
vamos a considerarlo todavía más extremo
de esto que sea menor al 1% y nosotros
decimos bueno claro para que ocurra esto
que está pasando en la hipótesis nula
tenemos una probabilidad de menos del 1
por ciento es decir tenemos una
probabilidad muy escasa entonces lo
rechazamos y lo rechazamos más que nada
por una cuestión de sentido común o de
lógica no porque algo nos esté
asegurando que no puede ocurrir porque
puede ocurrir existe un 1 por ciento de
probabilidades de que ocurra sin embargo
nosotros la rechazamos este error tipo 1
se hace referencia a esto de rechazarlo
aun cuando tenemos una probabilidad
mínima mínima aunque sea 0 0 0 1 % de
que ocurra
es decir que este error es muy común no
es alguna equivocación uno siempre va a
rechazar la hipótesis nula cuando
tenemos una probabilidad tan baja sin
embargo existe esa probabilidad de
haberla rechazado aún cuando era
verdadera veamos un ejemplo supongamos
que tenemos
la distribución normal dada por x es
decir creamos la distribución
normal y vemos cuál es la probabilidad
de obtener el valor que buscamos tenemos
nuestro mundo
su xv hará la distribución muestral
o mejor aún trabajamos con una
distribución normal no con una muestra
tenemos la distribución normal y vemos
cuál es la probabilidad por ejemplo de
obtener un valor
que esté acá en el 1%
tenemos 1 % entonces como la
probabilidad de que ocurra un evento acá
es de 1% supongamos que la rechazamos
pero supongamos que
ocurre esto ocurre quizás con un 0 5 %
no sólo 1% tenemos un 0.5 entonces
también le rechazamos
por lo tanto
rechazamos
la hipótesis nula
estaríamos cometiendo el error de tipo 1
es decir para aceptar una hipótesis en
este caso la hipótesis alternativa
estamos dejando de lado estamos
decidiendo estamos tomando la decisión
de cometer el error tipo 1 que es el de
rechazar la hipótesis nula aún cuando
sea verdadera otra cosa que vale aclarar
es que la probabilidad de cometer el
error tipo 1 de haberlo cometido
supongamos que bueno en verdad lo que
sucedía era lo de la hipótesis nula pero
bueno nos dio una probabilidad tan baja
sin embargo era lo que sucedía la
probabilidad de haber cometido ese error
de tipo 1 es el nivel de significación
que tenemos es decir si nosotros tenemos
una probabilidad de 1% de que ocurra ese
caso extremo que nos entregaba la
hipótesis alternativa
entonces el error de haber cometido el
la probabilidad de haber cometido el
error de tipo 1 rechazando la hipótesis
nula es justamente del 1%